[Music]
foreign
okay I'm the homelander I'm I am
homelander
as a superhero sometimes you have to do
things so why did I do it I did it
because it's the right thing to do quite
simply I did it because it's the right
thing to do
there you go everybody loves you because
you're perfect
firefighters are the real heroes you got
five firefighters
you guys are the real heroes
you oh God
teachers teacher teachers teachers
teachers are the custodians of our youth
they are the real
Heroes you do nothing you think you can
do what I do
it
nobody can do what I do
yeah
I'm the homelander I'm the homelander
and I can do whatever the [__] I want
foreign
[Music]